EROV AND THE TOP LINE
IS OUT
HOLE OF DARCY KUEMPER, AND IT IS
HIS 11th OF THE PLAYOFFS AND BYH
THE SPEED, AND HE WENT IN TO  T
IS PAT MAROON WITH ARUTTA, AND
HEDMAN TURNS IT TOAMKOS.
THE PASS IS OFF, AND RETURN PASE
SAME, AND DOWN LOW! TAMPA BAY
LINEUP COMES T, AND
THROWN DOWN LOW BY AND
IT IS GOING TO BE TIGHT FOR THE
NEXT 40 MINUTES.  THROUGH VASIL
WE AREMANSON, AND ACROSS THE
ICE IT GOES, AND CAROMS BACK TO
PERRY GETS A SHOT OFF AS HE WAS
SOME CHANCES THROUGH THE S LEHK
WHERE IS THE NET?
MORE PENALTYS THE, BUT IT DOES
NOT MEAN ANYTHING.
AND NICHSHKIN WITH THE
ARTTURI LEHKONEN MAKES IT 2-1,
COLORADO.
OTHE --
MOVE IT THE OTHER WAY, AND IT IS
GOING NOW, AND ONE-HANDERBELLEM
KILLORN DOES NOT
CRITICAL.
>> Sean: RANTANEN WALKING RIGHT
LIGHTNING HAVE BEEN TAKEN BY
EITHER STAMKOS OR PERRY DOWN LOY
IS GOING TO BE COMING IN
INTERFERENCE, AND RIGHT IN FRONT
THE AND NICHSHKIN
IS TRAIL, AND BACK IT GOES
LANDESKOG, AND HE IS TRYING TO
JAM IT.
VASILEVSKIY HAS IT FROZEN UPND M
IT, BUT IT IS NOT A RISKY PLAY.
THEY ARE
AMERICA.
STAMKOS DOWN LOW, AND SHOTHE IS
SHOT HER BY
BIG ICING CALL BY
TWO STARS IN MacKINNON AND
STAMKOS, AND JUST AN AMAZING
SERIES, AND AND